[Applause]
televised presidential debates have been
an American political tradition for the
past 60 years but while they're far from
perfect they're still beneficial to
voters as a means to learn about a
candidate that was locker-room talk
what's more they can make or break an
election so what if anything can be done
to improve them the candidates need no
introduction it's telling that the first
ever televised presidential debate in
1960 between candidates Richard Nixon
and John F Kennedy remains famous not
for what was said but for how each
candidate look senator Kennedy although
Nixon and Kennedy talked extensively
about the big issues of the time like
the Cold War and civil rights what is
best remembered today is each
candidate's appearance the mix of
Kennedy debates in 1960 we're actually
the beginning of the modern televised
debate era there was actually four
debates in 1960 but what everybody
remembers is the first debate where
Kennedy looked healthy and Nixon looked
sweaty and sick he paid a price for that
and what people remembered was how they
looked not what they said for better or
worse the Kennedy Nixon matchup set a
precedent of style over substance that's
only grown more prevalent and televised
debates what tends to be remembered from
debates are moments and usually they're
moments of gaffes or mistakes not high
moments or great moments that was the
case with the next debate in 1976 when
President Gerald Ford faced off against
his Democratic challenger Jimmy Carter
what Ford said really wasn't a gaffe it
just sort of came out not the way he
intended it to be
there is no Soviet domination Eastern
Europe and there never will be under a
Ford administration what he said
essentially was that the people of
Poland don't consider themselves to be
subjugated to Soviet rule and that was
true the way it came across and the way
was portrayed unfortunately for him was
that he was naive he thought that Polish
people weren't really under the Soviet
thumb when in fact of course in those
days they were that's again what
everybody remembered from that debate
and it didn't help him you already are
the Oh
president and history poignant moments
in the debate can also help the
candidate in 1984 Ronald Reagan famously
put questions about his age to bed with
this quip I will not make age an issue
of this campaign I am NOT going to
exploit for political purposes my
opponents youth and inexperience in the
first debate Reagan didn't look all that
good he looked a little old he was
stumbling around a bit that produced
some stories including ironically a
famous one in the front page of The Wall
Street Journal that said the age factor
has arisen so the reagan campaign knew
going into that debate they had an age
issue to deal with they did defuse the
age question for the rest of that
campaign modern debates also have the
added pressure of going viral
sometimes debate moments that don't go
well can be not just bad they can be
almost fatal it's three agencies of
government when I get there that are
gone commerce education and the what's
the third one there let's see that was
the case for Rick Perry in 2011 when he
got halfway into a debate answer and
then couldn't remember the rest of it
the third one I can't or Mitt Romney's
famous slip-up in 2012 I went to a
number of women's groups and said can
you help us find folks and they brought
us whole binders full of women he was
trying to say that I have paid attention
to advancing women in my career I have a
record of doing it but it came across
badly it came across in a way that made
it look as if women were nothing but
sheets of paper and a binder to him
clearly debates can have an effect on
the outcome of an election but what can
be done to improve them I think it's
crucial when you're analyzing debates to
distinguish between primary season
debates and general election debates
there are two quite different animals
and I think in my opinion one works way
better than the other primary debates
tend to be free-for-alls where there's
no particular format or formula from one
debate to the next they tend to be
sponsored by media organizations
sometimes by state parties sometimes by
combinations of all of the above
in contrast the general election debates
are a bit more sober and controlled
general election debates are conducted
with the Commission of presidential
debates which was established in 1987
which has done this through eight
presidential cycles and which knows how
to do it right in a distinguished way
proposal is to remove live studio
audiences and from The Wall Street
Journal dairy side well first of all
I've done three debates with live
audiences who are partisans and so I
know what the atmosphere is like and it
could be problematic it is basically
becomes a campaign rally to some extent
and I don't think it's the ideal way to
hold a presidential debate oh yes we're
gonna take your ar-15 your ak-47 a
smaller audience that is not filled with
campaign partisans is a better way to go
another at least for the primaries is to
reduce the number of candidates on stage
that debate with too many candidates is
very unwieldy it's hard to conduct a
meaningful substantive conversation that
follows a logical progression we don't
have time for talk the biggest question
hanging over the 2020 debates is the
issue of President Donald Trump's
participation what President Trump has
said is that he thinks the debate
commission was unfair to him in 2016 and
he's not sure he's going to agree to do
the three presidential debates that they
have set up I think that would be a
mistake I think would be bad for the
country bad for the campaign bad for
democracy it's easy to be critical of
debates because they could be very messy
and they're not always perfect well when
I think about debates I think a little
bit about what Winston Churchill said
about democracy he said democracy is the
worst form of government except every
other form of government that anybody's
ever tried they can be messy they're not
perfect but there a better way to get
the candidates to address voters and
address each other and address issues
than anything else I can think of
you